A talking hippo, a mystic bangle, and psychic
communication with a dinosaur? All in Marvel
shows? In order for all this insanity to make
sense you'll have to watch them in this order!
Warning: This video contains fast, flashing
images. Viewer discretion is advised,
especially for those with photosensitive epilepsy.
"Agent Carter" — which aired two seasons
on ABC from 2015 to 2016 — is our starting
point, as it's the best overall
introduction to the Marvel world.
It's also the earliest program in Marvel's
in-story chronology. The events of "Agent
Carter" occur following 2011's "Captain America:
The First Avenger," with Hayley Atwell reprising
her role as Peggy Carter. Rather than revolve
solely around the eponymous protagonist,
"Agent Carter" delves deeper into the backstory
of characters like Edwin Jarvis, Howard Stark,
Daniel Sousa, and Dottie Underwood who
all have wider connections to the MCU.
Unfortunately, ABC canceled "Agent Carter" before
it could fully depict the origins of S.H.I.E.L.D.,
as it was originally billed to do.
The second season ends in 1946,
while Peggy doesn't become the director
of S.H.I.E.L.D. until 1949. However,
while the series doesn't quite fulfill its initial
directive, it's still a solid, entertaining show
that helps to establish a stronger backstory
for Peggy, so it shouldn't be missed.
"Strategic homeland intervention
enforcement and logistics division.”
“And what does that mean to you?”
“It means someone really wanted
our initials to spell out SHIELD."
In 2013, Marvel Television launched "Agents
of S.H.I.E.L.D." on ABC. The series introduces
viewers to a group of S.H.I.E.L.D. agents led by
the recently revived Phil Coulson, played by Clark
Gregg, who is seemingly killed by Loki, played
by Tom Hiddleston, in 2012's "The Avengers."
"S.H.I.E.L.D." begins after the events
of "The Avengers" and 2013's "Iron Man
3." Although it more or less
evolves into a standalone show,
Seasons 1 and 2 of "S.H.I.E.L.D." closely follow
events from the MCU film timeline. For example,
in Season 1, Episode 8 follows up on the aftermath
of 2013's "Thor: The Dark World," and the Season
1 finale mirrors the events that take place in
2014's "Captain America: The Winter Soldier."
The series also includes brief appearances
from Nick Fury, played by Samuel L. Jackson,
and Maria Hill, played by Cobie Smulders.
When S.H.I.E.L.D. is destroyed, Fury puts
Coulson in charge of rebuilding the agency his
own way from the ground up. This rebuilding
proves both figurative and literal, in the
respect that it marks a point for "Agents
of S.H.I.E.L.D." to go in a new direction,
away from rigidly following the MCU timeline.
Netflix's Marvel era started in 2015
with "Daredevil" and "Jessica Jones."
"Daredevil" — which stars Charlie Cox as
Daredevil, aka Matt Murdock — arrived on
the streamer first. As a blind lawyer by day and
a vigilante by night, Murdock does everything he
can to protect the residents of the section
of New York City known as Hell's Kitchen.
"Daredevil" makes sense to watch after the first
two seasons of "S.H.I.E.L.D." for a couple of
reasons. First, the first episode of "Daredevil"
explains that something like a couple of years
has passed since the Battle of New York from
"The Avengers," which means "Daredevil" begins
around the time Season 2 of "S.H.I.E.L.D." ends.
Second, Episode 2 references Carl "Crusher" Creel,
aka Absorbing Man, a villain who
shows up in Season 2 of "S.H.I.E.L.D."
"Daredevil" is also the perfect foundation for
introducing the rest of New York's street-level
vigilantes, making it the obvious segue
into "Jessica Jones." Krysten Ritter plays
the reluctant do-gooder who's sworn off superhero
life, opting to put her powers to use as a private
investigator. The first season follows Jessica
Jones as she deals with a demon from her past.
For an intuitive watching sequence,
"Daredevil" Season 2 is the thematic
choice after "Jessica Jones" Season
1, and "Luke Cage" comes after.
Season 1 of "Jessica Jones" introduces
Luke Cage, played by Mike Colter,
so you'll already be familiar with Netflix's third
vigilante hero if you follow our watch order.
The first season of "Luke Cage" overlaps
with "Daredevil" Season 2 a little bit,
so we recommend watching them one
after the other. By the end of the
first season of "Luke Cage," the events
of "Daredevil" Season 2 have taken place.
"The more I hit him, the more he dished
out. So I stopped feeding him hate."
Danny Rand, played by Finn Jones, rounds out
Netflix's roster of righteous vigilantes. Rand,
aka Iron Fist, gets his mystical powers by
defeating the dragon Shou-Lao, rather than
from accidental or external forces, as is more
typically the case for New York's street-level
heroes. Debuting on Netflix in 2017, the
series follows Danny Rand as he returns
to New York with his powers. When the pressure
of being the last living member of the wealthy
Rand Family combines with the duties of the
Iron Fist, it turns out to be a lot to handle.
After watching the first season of "Iron Fist,"
you'll be primed for "The Defenders" — a limited
series that brings together the title characters
from four of Netflix's Marvel shows. It takes
place several weeks after the events of Season 1
of "Iron Fist," but picks up story threads from
all four associated programs. Showrunner Marco
Ramirez explained in a Den of Geek article,
"Daredevil" introduces Jon Bernthal's take on
Frank Castle, aka the Punisher — a quintessential
antihero whose methods of cleaning up New York
City tend to get a little more homicidal than his
fellow crimefighters. Before his own show starts,
he's last seen in the "Daredevil" Season 2 finale,
but doesn't reprise his role for "The
Defenders." "The Punisher" provides an
in-story explanation for Frank's absence from
the limited series, although showrunner Marco
Ramirez told The Hollywood Reporter the real
culprit was Bernthal's lack of availability.
When "The Punisher" begins, a few
months on from the most recent
events of "Daredevil," Frank Castle is
working in construction under the name
Pete Castiglione. He doesn't
remain in retirement for long.
Netflix canceled "The Punisher"
after two seasons — which we
recommend watching back-to-back
after "The Defenders." In 2020,
writer-director Adam G. Simon pitched a film
based on "The Punisher" to Marvel Studios.
He imagined it would be tonally similar to a
film like "Logan" per Comicbook.com. He added,
Sadly, it's unlikely Simon's pitch
will ever come to fruition ... but
that doesn't mean we'll never see
Frank Castle again in the MCU.
Since Jessica Jones, Luke Cage, and Danny Rand are
fresh from their foray together as the Defenders,
it makes sense to continue their stories
before moving back to "S.H.I.E.L.D."
Out of these three second seasons, it makes
the most sense to start with "Jessica Jones,"
chronologically. There's a lot going on in
"Jessica Jones'' Season 2; the reluctant hero
struggles to move past her recent encounters with
Kilgrave, played by David Tennant. In addition,
the sophomore batch of "Jessica Jones'' episodes
bring a lot more of her history to the screen,
including the story behind how
exactly she got her powers.
Season 2 of "Luke Cage" — in which the
man with unbreakable skin has become a
sort of superhero mascot of Harlem, and must
contend with the baggage and responsibilities
of celebrity – is the natural progression
from Season 2 of "Jessica Jones." Danny
Rand appears in Season 2 of "Luke Cage"
before the second season of "Iron Fist,"
and it's more than a mere cameo. After
the crossover, there are three episodes
of "Luke Cage" left to watch before you
can dive into Season 2 of "Iron Fist."
"But this city rejected you,
it beat you. I beat you."
Out of Marvel's Netflix shows, only "Daredevil"
and "Jessica Jones" return for a third season, so
it makes the most sense to watch them when their
previous seasons are still fresh in your mind.
Daredevil is last seen several
in-story months ago in "The
Defenders." Viewers know he survives
after seemingly sacrificing himself,
and this third season clarifies exactly how
that happens. Meanwhile, the third season of
"Jessica Jones" picks up about three months
after the events of Season 2. Viewers who are
correctly miffed that "Luke Cage" comes to
an abrupt and inconclusive end with Season 2
can enjoy some degree of closure when he briefly
returns in the series finale of "Jessica Jones."
Both "Daredevil" and "Jessica Jones''
conclude with their third seasons,
temporarily bringing the storylines of all
of Netflix's vigilantes to a close. However,
whether they're all gone for good remains
to be seen. In 2021, audiences saw Daredevil
reemerge in "Spider-Man: No Way Home," and
The Kingpin, played by Vincent D'Onofrio,
return to television in Disney+'s "Hawkeye."
Could more Jessica Jones or Luke Cage be far off?
After watching every season of Marvel's
streaming Netflix shows uninterrupted — which,
let's be honest, just makes sense —
it's time to check in with Director
Phil Coulson and his team from network television.
While the third season of "S.H.I.E.L.D." was
broadcast around the same time as 2015's "Ant-Man
'' and 2016's "Captain America: Civil War '' hit
theaters, the show stopped reflecting the events
of the MCU after Season 2, forging ahead in its
own direction. The second season ends with a box
of Terrigen crystals falling into the ocean and
contaminating Earth's water supply, causing anyone
with Inhuman DNA to go through the Terrigenesis
process that activates their innate powers.
While some S.H.I.E.L.D. agents search for
Inhumans, Daisy Johnson, played by Chloe Bennet,
gets a handle on her Inhuman powers and
builds a team of Secret Warriors. Meanwhile,
Grant Ward, played by Brett Dalton,
looks to rebuild HYDRA, and Leo Fitz,
played by Iain De Caestecker, figures out that
the Monolith is an extraterrestrial portal that
may have transported Jemma Simmons, played by
Elizabeth Henstridge, to an unknown planet.
If that makes it sound like "S.H.I.E.L.D." Season
3 has a lot to unpack, that's because it does.
The third season of "Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D."
deals with alien planets, Terrigenesis,
and the search for more Inhumans. All
those Inhuman-related components make
"S.H.I.E.L.D" Season 3 the perfect
predecessor to Marvel's "Inhumans."
"We face an uncertain future,
but we face it with hope."
In 2017, the first two episodes of "Inhumans" were
released in IMAX theaters before the remaining six
episodes premiered on ABC. This single-season
series follows the Inhuman Royal Family,
led by King Blackagar Boltagon, aka Black Bolt,
played by Anson Mount. Generations ago, Black
Bolt fled Earth and created Attilan, an Inhuman
safe haven on the Moon. When Black Bolt notices
the Terrigen outbreak on Earth, from Seasons 2 and
3 of "S.H.I.E.L.D.", he sends his cousin Triton,
played by Mike Moh, to rescue any Inhumans who
are on the run and bring them back to Attilan.
However, this doesn't exactly go according to
plan when Black Bolt's mad brother Maximus,
played by Iwan Rheon, tries to usurp the throne.
"Inhumans" might not technically be an
"Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D." spinoff, but
"Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D.: Slingshot" clearly is.
The six-part web series focuses on S.H.I.E.L.D.
newcomer Elena "Yo-Yo" Rodriguez, played by
Natalia Cordova-Buckley. Yo-Yo is being forced
to sign the Sokovia Accords, but this interferes
with a personal mission she must complete.
"Slingshot" was technically released midway
through the fourth season of "S.H.I.E.L.D.",
but the events in it take place before
the beginning of the season. The main
cast members of "S.H.I.E.L.D." are also
present in "Slingshot." Cordova-Buckley
explained to IGN that the web
series is meant to help viewers,
"understand the reasoning for many of the
decisions that characters make in Season 4."
"Slingshot" also realigns "S.H.I.E.L.D."
with the MCU timeline, placing it
sometime after the Sokovia Accords are
introduced in 2016's "Captain America:
Civil War." The relationship between
"S.H.I.E.L.D." and the MCU timeline
becomes even clearer with the introduction of
Robbie Reyes, played by Gabriel Luna — thus far,
the only version of Ghost Rider to canonically
appear in any MCU-adjacent live-action media.
The middle of the season focuses on Reyes' very
mystic storyline. By no coincidence, this season
of "S.H.I.E.L.D." aired around the same time
2016's "Doctor Strange" was released in theaters.
After Season 4 of "Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D."
introduces you to Robbie Reyes, aka the Spirit
of Vengeance, it's the perfect time to meet
Daimon and Satana "Ana" Helstrom. The series,
"Helstrom," has a darker tone than some
of Marvel's other shows, and Daimon and
Ana definitely aren't your typical heroes. The
siblings, played by Tom Austen and Sydney Lemmon,
are the offspring of a prolific serial killer.
On a quest to redeem their family legacy,
they use their occult know-how to
hunt down the worst of humanity.
Watching "Helstrom" after "S.H.I.E.L.D." Season 4
is perfect timing from a thematic standpoint.
It's also the only true standalone series on
this list, as it doesn't cross over with
"S.H.I.E.L.D." or any other Marvel shows.
On its surface, Freeform's "Cloak
& Dagger" looks like a standalone
show. It's set in New Orleans rather than
New York, and it follows two superpowered
teens – Tyrone Johnson, played by
Aubrey Joseph, and Tandy Bowen,
played by Olivia Holt — rather than adult
superheroes. However, comic book fans might
notice "Cloak & Dagger" has more connections
to the MCU than a passing glance indicates.
The presence of the Roxxon Corp.
— a crooked energy corporation,
and Cloak and Dagger's primary antagonist —
connects the series to the "Iron Man'' franchise,
"Agent Carter," "Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D.," and
Marvel's former Netflix shows. In Season 1,
this program's dynamic duo's frenemy in
the police department Brigid O'Reilly,
played by Emma Lahana, mentions knowing Misty
Knight, played by Simone Missick. Season 2
includes a scene where Tyrone discusses
a newspaper article about Luke Cage.
However, despite the show's indirect connections
to several of the aforementioned Marvel shows,
both seasons of "Cloak & Dagger"
are perfectly placed here,
because the biggest crossover of the
series is with the next show on our list.
"What do we do?”
“We run."
Despite Season 2's decline in ratings, "Cloak
& Dagger" proved that an audience for teen
superheroes definitely exists, which can also
be said of Marvel's "Runaways." The show follows
six Los Angeles teens who unite against their
criminal parents, discovering their superpowers
in the process. As it happens, one of their powers
entails psychic communication with a dinosaur.
"Runaways" premiered on Hulu in 2017,
and is set around the same general time
as "Cloak & Dagger." Tandy and Tyrone even
appear in two episodes of "Runaways" Season 3.
Along with its "Cloak & Dagger '' crossover,
Season 3 of "Runaways' ' might also connect
the show to the wider MCU by
introducing Morgan le Fey,
played by Elizabeth Hurley. The sinister
sorceress attempts to wield the power of
the Darkhold — a tome of dark magic last seen at
the end of Season 4 of "Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D."
when Ghost Rider takes it to hell. Maybe we
shouldn't assume Morgan le Fey's Darkhold and
Ghost Rider's Darkhold are the same grimoire
... but we can't assume they aren't, either.
For the most part, "Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D."
might as well exist on its own timeline during
its final three seasons. However, a few brief
events from Season 5 tie in with 2017's "Thor:
Ragnarok" and 2018's "Avengers: Infinity
War," which makes the last three years of
"S.H.I.E.L.D." a perfect TV binge to
bring the MCU's Phase 3 to a close.
The first half of "S.H.I.E.L.D." Season 5 is set
in a dystopian future which has no bearing on the
MCU timeline. However, an off-the-cuff remark from
Noah, played by Joel David Moore, in Episode 11
about an Asgardian walking the streets of New York
— presumably a reference to Thor's visit to the
Big Apple in "Ragnarok" – gives Season 5 a loose
sense of place within the larger MCU timeline.
However, even though the end of
Season 5 runs alongside "Avengers:
Infinity War," the season doesn't end with
the snap. According to showrunner Jed Whedon,
the minds behind "S.H.I.E.L.D" avoided the
major plot point out of concern that their
unpredictable broadcast schedule could lead to
"S.H.I.E.L.D." accidentally spoiling the movie.
The final season of "S.H.I.E.L.D." sees the
team literally jumping through time. During
a "S.H.I.E.L.D." adventure in 1955, the show
resolves the question of Peggy Carter and Daniel
Sousa's relationship status ... which seems a
little redundant, considering 2019's "Avengers:
Endgame" makes it pretty clear she ends up
with Steve Rogers, played by Chris Evans.
"It wasn't so hard to fit in, after all.”
“And all we had to do was be ourselves.”
“Well, with a few modifications."
By the time the events of the MCU's designated
Phase 4 begins, Marvel Television has been
absorbed by Marvel Studios in the real
world. As a consequence, Marvel TV shows
greenlit after this point tend to sync up with
the films more overtly than we'd gotten used to.
The 2021 limited series "WandaVision" is the
first show in an extensive line of Marvel series
for the Disney+ streaming platform. Elizabeth
Olsen and Paul Bettany reprise their roles as
Wanda Maximoff and The Vision, and the story
spins off directly from "Avengers: Endgame."
"WandaVision" has particularly
transformative implications for
Wanda. The tale ends with her officially
claiming the title of the Scarlet Witch,
after years of everyone acting like her superhero
codename was "Wanda". "WandaVision" also sets up
the Scarlet Witch's character arc for 2022's
"Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of Madness."
While the series does a lot to move Marvel TV
forward, "WandaVision" also links back to past
Marvel projects. Wanda gains possession of
a book called "the Darkhold" — which could
connect "WandaVision" to "Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D."
and "Runaways." But more directly, "WandaVision"
reintroduces characters from other MCU films,
including Darcy Lewis, played by Kat Dennings,
from the first two Thor movies, and Jimmy Woo,
played by Randall Park, from 2018's "Ant-Man
and the Wasp." Hopefully, the speculation of
a Darcy and Woo spinoff proves to be accurate.
After the events of "Avengers: Endgame,"
Sam Wilson, played by Anthony Mackie,
and Bucky Barnes, played by Sebastian Stan,
reunite in "The Falcon and the Winter Soldier."
In this single-season series, Sam and Bucky are
both dealing with their grief over Steve Rogers'
departure from their lives in their own ways.
The story kicks off when Sam rejects Captain
America's shield, while Bucky faces up to the
acts of horrific violence he committed during
his time as the Winter Soldier. "Falcon
and the Winter Soldier" dives into the
backstory of both central characters while
following its central plotline — multiple
groups attempting to foil an anarchist
organization known as the Flag Smashers.
"The Falcon and the Winter Soldier" serves
as a stepping-stone for these characters to
reach their next steps in the MCU. Eventually,
"Falcon and the Winter Soldier" concludes with
Sam taking on the mantle of Captain America
and, of course, receiving his new costume.
Christmas of 2024, remember, the MCU
is a few years ahead of the real world,
sees semi-retired Avenger Clint Barton, aka
Hawkeye, played by Jeremy Renner, back in action
with an unofficial protégé, Kate Bishop, played by
Hailee Steinfeld. Kate prefers to think of herself
as Clint's partner rather than his sidekick,
but let's not waste time splitting hairs...
The series takes place after "Avengers:
Endgame," "WandaVision," and "The Falcon and
the Winter Soldier." It also sets up at least
one upcoming Marvel show by introducing Echo,
played by Alaqua Cox, and establishing
her connection with Wilson Fisk — played,
as he is in "Daredevil," by Vincent D'Onofrio.
"Hawkeye" is billed as a limited series. A
second season hasn't been officially ruled out,
but even if we never get more episodes of
"Hawkeye" it seems reasonable to expect more
from its characters, particularly Echo, Kate,
and Yelena Belova, played by Florence Pugh.
"Kate Bishop! Hi!"
The first season of "Loki" technically
takes place straight after "Avengers:
Endgame," around the same time as "WandaVision,"
although it was released between "The Falcon and
the Winter Soldier" and "Hawkeye." However, the
show's place in the chronological timeline gets
a little funky, as "Loki" takes viewers back
to 2012, introduces a series of new timelines,
and eventually confirms the
existence of the Multiverse.
The series ends with Tom Hiddleston's God
of Mischief fracturing the multiverse and
landing in an alternate reality where a
presumably evil variant of He Who Remains,
played by Jonathan Majors, rules
over The Time Variance Authority.
"Loki'' adds an element of chaos and
creates infinite possibilities for the
MCU. Like "WandaVision'' and "The Falcon and
the Winter Soldier," "Loki'' is an important
part of the Marvel canon, shaping the
future of the multiverse saga. It's
also the only live-action Disney+ Marvel
show so far with a confirmed Season 2.
"What If...?" fits nicely alongside
"Loki," as its premiere ties into
the cliffhanger of "Loki" Season 1.
The series sees characters like Captain
Carter and the Star Lord version of T'Challa
make their MCU debut. "What If...?" also
welcomes Marvel film actors like Benedict
Cumberbatch and Chris Hemsworth who
made their debut on the television
side of things by voicing versions of their
big screen characters. Tragically, "What
If..." includes one of the final performances
from "Black Panther" star Chadwick Boseman.
After Captain Carter crossed
over into "Doctor Strange
in the Multiverse of Madness",
the possibility for more "What
if…?" characters to cross over into
live action is very much a reality.
Oscar Isaac makes his MCU debut
as Marc Spector and Stephen Grant
in "Moon Knight," the next installment
in Marvel's Phase 4 television roster,
and the first to reach the small screen in 2022.
The series definitely takes place after the Blip,
since an ad for the Global Repatriation
Council, or GRC, is visible in Episode 2.
As viewers might remember, the GRC makes its first
appearance in "The Falcon and the Winter Soldier."
Release order is, of course, not the
only factor in the placement of "Moon
Knight" on this list. The series
establishes itself as more of a
standalone show that delves into Isaac's
character or, to put it more precisely,
his characters. Executive producer Grant
Curtis explained in a press release,
However, that doesn't mean Isaac's appearance
is a one-off. In fact, it's quite the opposite,
as Marvel Studios President Kevin Feige
confirmed to The Hollywood Reporter that
Moon Knight will cross over with the
MCU films at some point in the future.
"Good is not a thing you are,
Kamala, It's a thing you do."
Next up on this list is "Ms. Marvel", the teen
superhero series starring Iman Vellani as Kamala
Khan. Like Oscar Isaac's characters, Vellani
introduces the well-known comic book hero,
Ms. Marvel, to the screen. However, her character
is not an exact translation of the comics.
While Vellani's character might
not be exactly the same on screen,
she has been hailed for bringing wider
diversity to the superhero world. "Ms.
Marvel" follows Kamala as she uncovers and
comes into her superhero powers, and It's
not long before she discovers all the secrets and
dangers that come along with her mystic bangle.
Marvel viewers who love "Hawkeye" will
adore this series, as both begin similarly
with Kate and Kamala fawning over their
favorite Avengers. However, unlike Kate,
who faces the Tracksuit Mafia with Clint as
her partner, Kamala tries to figure out her
other-worldly powers on her own — or at least
with the help of Bruno, played by Matt Lintz,
and Kamran, played by Rish Shah. She doesn't
even get to meet her hero, though they do
seemingly swap places in the finale's post-credits
scene, which sets up an exciting Phase 4 team.
Ms. Marvel will next appear alongside
Brie Larson's Captain Marvel and
Teyonah Parris's Monica Rambeau
in the 2023 film "The Marvels."
Like Oscar Isaac and Iman Vellani, Tatiana Maslany
debuts a new MCU superhero on the small screen,
taking on the role of lawyer Jennifer Walters, or
She-Hulk. Jennifer gets her powers after her blood
becomes contaminated with her cousin Bruce
Banner's after a car accident. Mark Ruffalo
reprises his role as Bruce and Smart Hulk to train
his cousin. However, it quickly becomes clear that
she's got a better handle on her abilities and
can learn in hours things that took him years.
"She-Hulk" continues the development of new
Phase 4 characters also seen in "Hawkeye,"
"Moon Knight," and "Ms. Marvel," but it also
links back to the wider MCU. With Jennifer
in her new role at Goodman Lieber Kurtzberg &
Holliway, she practices law as her Hulk-self
and works with a handful of superhuman
clients who MCU viewers have seen before.
"She-Hulk" even picks up one of the unresolved
storylines from "Shang-Chi and the Legend of
the Ten Rings," explaining what happened after
Wong, played by Benedict Wong, and Emil Blonsky,
aka Abomination, played by Tim Roth, fought in
Xialing's club. As the series reaches its climax,
vigilante hero Daredevil, played by Charlie Cox,
joins the flight, helping the good guys win,
and the ending leaves for Jen and
Bruce to appear again in the MCU.